joining me now Saul weisenberg former
deputy independent Council on a Fox News
contributor Saul we're going to get to
that in a moment but I first want to
address this other issue in your
reaction again to Hunter's attorneys
saying that putting President Biden on
the stand would cause a quote
constitutional crisis what of that
it's an absolute joke and would be
considered an absolute joke by any
responsible prosecutor I would have
kicked somebody out of my office who
said that to begin with have they
forgotten that President William
Jefferson Clinton testified for the
defense in the in the Whitewater trial
he was a defense witness he testified at
the White House there was no
constitutional crisis they made
accommodations because he was President
so there's no constitutional crisis here
that's number one number two that
assumes that Joe Biden would ever really
want to testify or whether or not a
district judge would allow him to
testify allow the defense to put him on
because there'd have to be a threshold
sowing of some relevancy so it's a joke
is an argument and it's a bigger joke if
any prosecutor in the Department of
Justice took it seriously
well at this point when we see the uh
this evidence that they would not have
even asked Hunter for a plea in this
case
were it not for these whistleblowers
coming forward again what does this tell
you about the just the objective by any
objective measure what this
investigation was really like
it's it was I was astounded to hear that
it's it's the it's like the prosecutors
had Stockholm syndrome uh and there
there are so many things about this case
this is the thing I want to stress to
your viewers there are so many things
about this case within the Department of
Justice that are just simply not how
it's done they are not by the book they
are not Kosher and this is just one of
them I could give you several examples
and just the statements alone the
inconsistent statements Alone by Weiss
since this story broke or or just
appalling first saying that he did have
the authority then limiting that and
here's the key thing that he has never
refuted he has never
in any way refuted or denied that at
that meeting on May 22nd uh sorry May 7
2022 meeting he told a room full of FBI
and IRS criminal agents that he did not
have the authority to prosecute Hunter
Biden and that Authority had been denied
by the D.C U.S attorney's office that is
completely inconsistent with him saying
that he had ultimate Authority and
completely inconsistent with everything
Merrick Garland said about the case
well Santa
's um
moment about the New York Times
reporting on this watch
politics I think without a doubt uh have
been injected into this investigation
and it's been very clear for for a long
time but what the the story that the
stories that emerged this weekend
clearly uh show that there were at least
some people involved in this
investigation who were ready to to to
end this
solve your reaction
well the of course that's true and the
amazing thing about if by ready to end
it means kill it uh I think that's true
and the amazing thing is the decision
had been made uh by Weiss uh in 2022
ultimately and by the department uh the
the doj tax uh there's enough to indict
here and you can indict here and then
the defensive the hunters defense
attorneys hear about it and go in and
start lobbying and it's all over he just
rolls them really quite stunning
uh bakari sellers is a former
congressman from South Carolina he was
talking about the comparison between
what is being alleged against the Biden
family and Donald Trump and all the
indictments coming forward check this
out
there is a whole lot of what about ISM
when it comes to Hunter Biden but there
is a great deal of difference between
the multiple felony counts the president
of the United States is looking at
versus some activities or actions by
This president's son
yeah so they're trying to say well
there's there's just these Rumblings
about Biden's son and meanwhile we have
indictments piling up against Trump that
actually allege credible wrongdoing so
no neither neither I mean the other one
is up here and the other one's down
there
well why is why the question is why
isn't there an indictment against
Senator Biden the reason there isn't was
because of this political interference
and I I've never been impressed by what
about to me he's engaging in what
aboutism every every case should be
judged on its own merits and let me just
tell you the hunter Biden investigation
is a major black mark and a major on the
doj a major scandal in doj history and
there should have been as I said from
the very beginning there should have
been a special counsel and this is a
reason why I'm the only one apparently
in America who believes this they should
they should resuscitate the independent
Council statute you need real
Independence in this situation
so this is so wild on so many levels we
have a lot more to ask you but we're
going to bring you back tomorrow thanks
so much Saul hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else